لذا أود أن أسألك أيضًا عن
تقرير جمال خاشقجي اليوم ،
تقرير المخابرات الأمريكية عن
مقتل جمال خاشقجي ، صحيح التقسيم الوحشي
الذي تم إصداره ، يقرأ اقتباسًا نقيم
أن ولي عهد المملكة العربية السعودية
محمد بن سلمان
وافق على عملية في اسطنبول تركيا
لـ  القبض على
الصحفي السعودي جمال خاشقجي وقتلته
وزارة الخزانة اليوم
فرضت عقوبات على القوة السعودية التي
نفذت ذلك
والنائب السابق لرئيس
المخابرات العامة السعودية لدورها
في القتل
ولكن لا توجد عقاب مباشر
من الرئيس بايدن.  أم
لماذا هذا يرسل رسالة
إلى العالم مفادها أننا سوف نتسامح مع
هذا لا لنكن واضحين أن هذه
جريمة مروعة لا يمكن
التسامح معها أبدًا. لقد كان الرئيس بايدن
واضحًا أنه
ينوي إقامة علاقة مختلفة تمامًا
أه مع السعودية  العربية مما
فعل أسلافنا مما فعلته الإدارة السابقة
على أساس أه الشفافية
والمساءلة
نحن  بحاجة إلى بناء علاقة
لإنهاء الحرب في
اليمن لوقف الأزمة الإنسانية هناك
نحتاج إلى أن نكون قادرين على الدفاع ضد إيران
ووكلائها ،
لذلك كان واضحًا جدًا مع
القيادة السعودية بأننا ستكون لدينا
علاقة مختلفة تمامًا  مما فعلناه في
ظل الإدارة السابقة
، وننظر إلى حقيقة إصدار
هذا التقرير اليوم ،
فهي خطوة واحدة إلى الأمام في أنه بهذه
الطريقة تكون خطوة واحدة نحو
التزامه بالشفافية ، لذا اسمحوا لي فقط
بالمساءلة من خلال تقديم هذه
المعلومات من
خلال جعل  هذه المعلومات أفهمها
بشكل صحيح وهذا صحيح ،
لم يتم طرحها ، لذا لديك وجهة نظر عادلة جدًا
في قول ذلك ولكن هذا ليس
بالضبط ما قاله بنفسه عندما كان
مرشحًا للترشح لمنصب ، هذا
ما قاله
عن التاج  الأمير وجمال
خاشقجي خاشقجي قُتلا في الواقع وتم قطع
أوصاله وأنا أؤمن بأمر ولي
العهد
وسأوضح أننا لن نبيع في الواقع الكثير
أسلحة لهم
كنا في الواقع سنجعلهم
يدفعون الثمن
ونجعلهم في الواقع منبوذين لأنهم
هناك القليل جدًا
من قيمة الاسترداد الاجتماعي للحكومة الحالية في
المملكة العربية السعودية ، يجب أن
يحاسبوا ،
حسنًا ، إنه ليس كذلك  جعلهم منبوذين ،
ما تغير
قد أوضح لهم ،
وقد أوضحت إدارتنا بشكل
واضح أنه
لن يتم التسامح مع هذا ، وهذا لن يتم
التسامح معه
، وهناك اتخذنا خطوات اليوم
لاحظت الخزانة والدولة  نتخذ
اليوم خطوات
لمعاقبة الأفراد المتورطين
أه في هذا القتل المروع لذلك تم اتخاذ خطوات
واضحة وخطوات مهمة
لإملاء أن هذا ليس
شيئاً نتسامح معه
والرئيس بايدن كان واضحاً اليوم
أن هذا ليس شيئاً  أننا سوف
نتسامح مع المضي قدما